And everybody, Dr. Cutters, again, this video is talking about a step number one.
This is really your first step, and it's starting to get a handle on your auto immune
disease.
And it's an honest, self-assessment of triggers.
So this is where it does become difficult, because sometimes we don't know what's
triggering it, and we want to always go to your history of an honest assessment, self-assessment
of trying to figure this out.
What is triggering this thing?
This is where testing is so invaluable, because it can tell us, you know, the triggers
that you don't always see.
Remember, these are IgA reactions that are typically an IgE immediate response, where it's like
E.D.
the peanut in your throat starts to close off.
It's, you know, eating gluten, and you don't notice any symptoms for, you know, 16 to 20
hours.
How are you going to notice if this is a trigger for your auto immune disease?
It's difficult.
So I'm not making this step easy, but I'm saying that we do need to dig into this.
We need to figure this out.
What are my triggers that are firing off my immune reaction?
So this is the clinical management that we're talking about.
First piece, what are some different possible foods, some different possible chemicals, pathogens,
stressors, sleep issues?
We need to dig into all these different things for a self-assessment standpoint, and then
later, possibly if we can to do some testing to fine-tune what is firing these reactions.
So first, auto immunity, it can be fired by dietary proteins.
So if I have self-antibodies, antibodies to self-tissue, let's say I have antibodies to my thyroid
gland, therefore I have Hashimoto's disease, anything that I eat, if I have antibodies to
that dietary protein in that food, and I'm going to fire up an immune reaction because
I ate that food, it's going to then attack my thyroid gland.
So if I fire an immune response, I am going to kill, I will destroy, my immune system will
destroy that which I have antibodies against first.
So if I have antibodies against my thyroid, and I also have antibodies against gluten, and
I'm eating gluten, I'm firing this immune reaction in my gut, it's causing inflammation in my
gut, causing damage in my gut, causing damage in my brain, inflammation in my brain, but it's
also damaging my thyroid simply because I'm creating an immune response when I have self-antibodies
to a tissue.
So that's why it's important to look for these triggers, that's why it's important to assess
food intake.
If I have antibodies to different foods, and it's typically the proteins or the peptides
of the food, then I will destroy tissue when I eat foods that I have these antibodies against.
I can't overemphasize this, I have a bunch of videos on this, I'm going to try to scare you
but you've got to deal with this, so it's not even just what I just said, it's also cross-reacted
foods and cross-reacted immune reactions, and it gets even more complicated, it can be
different, combined foods, you can have a reaction to cooked corn or cooked carrots and
not to raw carrots, or vice versa, that's why it's good to do a test, but I don't, we can't
do a test, I always try to look at self-assessment here, try to make this easy peasy, try to look
at self-assessment, so in another video you'll see that sodium salt can be a major trigger for
autoimmune disease if you haven't seen that video catch that video, because that's a hidden thing,
that's not an immune reaction, that's not a sensitivity like I have antibodies to sodium, it's
simply this reaction that takes place at a certain percentage of people that have an autoimmune disease,
when they eat salt, it fires an attack on that organ, it's crazy, I know, it gets depressing,
it's like I can't salt my food, I'll take all the joy out of my life, but it's not this early
video, you have to stay away from it for life, so it doesn't mean you have to stay away from it
completely, it's impossible to, we do need sodium, but understanding that that could be a trigger,
look at that, boy what I do, that is it, I couldn't figure out which food it is, if I thought it was
corn or the corn chips, maybe it's the salt, could sugar spike sugar imbalances, glucose imbalances
in my bloodstream affect my autoimmune issue, yes, so look at that, boy I thought it was the
dairy in that brownie, and it's actually the sugar in that brownie, that's spiked a glucose reaction,
that's spiked a reaction of my body, food coloring, huge stay additives and calories are huge,
not just for kids, but these are huge inflammatory markers, especially with brain inflammation,
GMO sensitivity, pesticides, things like that, all these can ramp up my immune response,
the most common of these are gluten, dairy, corn, egg, with thyroid issues, you've got molecular
mimicry going on with gluten and the thyroid, so that is just, I mean if you have Hashimoto's,
nobody with Hashimoto's should be gluten, just cross that off your list period, there's just no
exceptions there, I don't care if you did a food antibody tested, it was negative for gluten,
it's a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland, so you know you have circulated peptides,
gland peptides, it's going to fire a reaction in your immune system, and it's going to kill thyroid
issues, so nobody with thyroid issues, or I should say everybody that has an autoimmune thyroid,
whether it be graves or Hashimoto's has got to be gluten free, dairy, molecular mimics with dairy
and gluten cross-reactants with dairy gluten are very common, corn, egg, night shades especially with
arthritis, like rheumatoid, psoriatic arthritis, very, very common, the night shades are a major
cause of inflammation there, sugar that I just talked about, glutamates in food,
huge things, especially if you have genetic conversion issues with the GAN genes and the other
glutamate genes that converts glutamate, which is an amino acid found in a lot of different things
in our proteins that we're eating, converts it readily to glutamate, glutamate becomes
a neurotransmitter, and it's an excitatory neurotransmitter causes a lot of brain inflammation,
a lot of issues, food additives, colorings, pesticides, chemicals that we're exposed to,
these are all possible triggers, these are the things you want to look at and do an honest
self-assessment of these things, sensitivity to chemicals and reaction to chemicals,
it can be because of impaired hepatic biotransformation, that's a fancy way of saying issues with
my detox pathways and my liver, impaired microbiome biotransformation, fancy way of saying issues with
phase 4, 5, and 6 detox pathways, if you don't know what that is, look at the detox course read my
book on the phases of detoxification, I'll have more information in this course on that as well.
Depletion of antioxidants, antioxidants are the sole purpose of helping to prevent oxidation,
so chemicals in our environment, why are they damaging to us, they cause oxidizing reactions
to ourselves, these are major cancer causers, okay, that's our major, major population of cancer,
people you've got to be understanding that this is a major, if not the most common cause of cancer,
is lack of antioxidants and exposure to oxidizing agents, these are found in your cosmetics,
found in your cleaning supplies, BPA, plastics, formaldehydes, glues, benzines from smoke,
cigarette smoke, car exhaust, pesticides, herbicides, these are the most common things that we see.
Huge issue, need to deal with these things and notice exposure to these things
and cut down on exposure to these things even if you don't feel like they're triggers, so we're
looking for triggers here again. Any other triggers, immune triggers, how common have I heard that
boy after I got sick, after I got COVID, after I got this vaccine, after I got another tick bite,
this flared the whole thing, I went into a moldy room and it flared the whole thing and it made
everything worse, very, very common to have susceptibility to pathogens where it causes reactivity
and of latent immune issues and latent viral issues, constipylated amstin bar virus,
issue constipylated live issue that had been latent for a long period of time, very, very common look
for these types of triggers. Stress is so often overlooked but it is because it's just kind of normal
that we have such work demands on us, we put such work demands on us and we just kind of overlook it,
don't overlook unhealthy relationships, don't overlook sleep issues and talk a little bit more
about that in a second, not having friends, I mean your Facebook friends are not your friends,
okay, you have to have close interpersonal relationships, study after study after study, talk about close
interpersonal relationships, get involved in a church, get involved in a support group, get involved in
a community of other people that like to do the things that you like to do, that can make the greatest
difference on your autoimmune responses and how your body can balance this, talk about personal
susceptibility, this is a key component to that. Increase stress decreases your immune response can
increase your risk of cancer, increases your risk of all sorts of toxicity issues because neurologically,
your parasympathetic control, parasympathetic nervous system controls your liver detoxification pathways
and when you're under a sympathetic demand, meaning you're under a hyper stress demand all the time,
your parasympathetics are going to be imbalanced, suppressed, your pathways, your neurological pathways
are going to be depressed, healthy immune responses going to be depressed, and your susceptibility to all
sorts of disease, including cancer goes way up, so can't overemphasize that. Assess them on a sleep
you're getting, are you really getting adequate sleep? You feel guilty for taking naps, are you getting
deep sleep? Are you feeling rested when you wake up? There's issues that can be with your cortisol,
your needles, your pituitary thyroid access that can cause all this, it can be as simple as I need
to start, you need some protein before I go to bed to I need to really get my hormones checked through
a full Dutch panel and see what is really causing this and it can be as simple as dealing with
that, but not getting enough sleep can kill you literally, so you really need to look at that
and be honest with yourself about that as well. I talked about exercise and overexercising,
certainly under exercising is a major component. You have a set of Terry lifestyle, you're not
out doing anything, well that's not going to help anybody, but overexercising can be equally a problem,
so if you are thinking that exercise and you grew up in a lifestyle that you were very athletic
and you think that's going to be your solution, I'm going to just try and start training for
a marathon or something like that, if you especially if you have any type of brain inflammation,
any microglial, private in the brain, certainly neural antibody formation, you can't overexercise,
you've got to go really slow, so make sure that you keep a balance with that. With all of this,
when we assess this, everybody's completely different, some people are going to react to
just different things, I can't go into a house with mold in it, if I grew to it, just tips me over,
but food colour it just throws me off, if I give my kid something with Terry, it just completely
blows them out. Everybody's going to be different with that, that's what this whole idea is,
fighting out where your balance is so that you can manage the best way you can because that's really
what we're talking about, it's lifestyle and managing this and keeping this balance, try to keep
your autoimmune disease in a state of remission, it's not talking about cure, it's balancing this
and remission, hey, I could live this way, but also to have you joy in your life, we don't want you
to eliminate everything in your diet, not have any joy in your life, but you have to get into balance,
that's the whole key. So that's what we're studying, we're continuing to study, know that I'm praying for
you and you're praying for me, I hope too, and we'll see you in the next video, bye bye.